godzilla sunday against arizona a run
over three and two thirds he threw just
46 pitches as he still works his way
back from that shoulder issue that
caused him to miss the first couple
months of the year i thought he took a
very big step forward in his last outing
the walks were down the command was much
better the split finger he could throw
for a strike and that is a key pitch for
him especially against lefties i think
some improvement can come with a little
bit of the fastball command but
especially the breaking ball some of
these potent right-handed bats in this
cubs lineup he's going to need a
breaking ball to get them off the
fastball working out of the stretch at
all times comes home and off we go with
a first pitch pop fly into shallow right
field zach mckinstry caught off by
mookie betts one pitch in one out to
open the night chris bryant over four
three strikeouts in game one last night
bryant swings and blasts one out towards
left center and you could forget it wow
chris bryant will touch them all two
pitches
and two first pitch swings that one
yields a homer for kb
number 15 he crushed it that is a big
time blast for kb and it's nice to see
him
swing the bat and be ready for that
first fastball that he gets he did it
the whole month of may and he tore up
the league and the cubs draw first blood
before they could even settle in with
their dodger dogs a 2-2
and he does chase
comes the worst change-up hitting team
in the national league and uses that
split change for his first strikeout
tonight
we'll throw it to righties he mostly
throws it to lefties but this is a good
one it looks like a fast ball away on
the corner and the bottom just dropped
out of it here's 2-1
as rizzo lost one to short right
mckinstry going out once again giving
way to boogie bets who makes the catch
and that will end the inning
one run one hit
jake arrieta is back with the cubs on a
one-year contract after three years in
philadelphia and we touched on it right
off at the top of the show but the era
has gone up six consecutive years since
his cyan season in 2015 and this 545 era
that he's got right now is by far the
worst of his career
the ball is just not sinking as much for
him the velocity is down the slider that
was just a devastating pitch just an
automatic out pitch is flattening and
not having the depth and he's actually
having to go to more curve balls and
change ups to make that differential and
that separation between his fastball and
his off speed stuff
2-2 swing and a miss struck him out
and one to turner
in the air hayward coming on slowing
down makes the catch in a nice easy one
two three inning for jake arrieta 002
for marietta
line drive face it a base hit for cody
bellinger and the dodgers have one here
in the second get the ball for the whole
team
and for bellinger his first hit since
returning
up change up for a ball
you can be out in front but because it's
up you've got plenty of time to reach it
bellinger runs on the first pitch and
he's in there
injecting a little life into dodgers
stadium
gavin lux coming up left-handed hitter
they're going to put the shift on to the
right side a 2-0 and a ground ball under
whistles glad bellinger to the play
throw to first
in time but the dodgers have tied the
game
bellinger in to score
a 3-4-3 put out and an rbi ground out
for gavin lux and then bias thinking
about going home but then hooks it over
to rizzo to get the out if they'll
record it out that is a straight eve for
a very good fielder 1-1 game bottom
three zach mckinstry leads it off
against jake arrieta hits a high fly
ball to center field ortega racing back
it's gone
first pitch ambush 2-1 dodgers
over the wall and straight away center
field
395 feet from home mckinstry's fourth
home run of the year this ball is
crushed jake arrieta in his roughest
games gives up a lot of home runs and
his good ones he gives up less than one
schwatz one down the line peeling
towards the corner it's a fair ball
in the foul ground it goes picked up by
hayward godzilla stopped at third and a
justin turner double
comes down by a run base is loaded for
the dodgers two outs the 2-2 pitch lying
tonight diving back in catch by half at
second base beautiful play by ian
he was positioned over near the bag he
moved toward the middle made the
backhanded grab he ended up on his chest
but hung on to that line drive big play
aj pollock
muscles one down the line to left that
will drop in for a base hit
he's got his way to second with a double
a little parachute shot
oh maybe six feet there it was
impossible for either peterson or baez
to get to it and so pollock is a board
with a one out double
here's a bouncing ball to short loving
it by us comes up throwing and that's
gonna end the inning after four dodgers
two cubs one seven pitch coming to the
former dodger jack peterson here's the
3-2
chopper to first months at his second
run luckster recovering gonzalez but
late
sending started with a broken bad base
hit from hayward he's at third now
peterson at first a hesitation
[Applause]
no runs one hit one wall two left after
four and a half dodgers two cups one and
this is a big moment in the game if lux
can deliver dodgers get a run or two
then they can exhale a bit deep breath
high let kick and the pitch ground ball
right side high hop for rizzo gloves it
throws to arietta at the bag and jake
gets out of the jam as the dodgers leave
the bases loaded in the fifth
[Applause]
[Music]
he's not afraid to hit you he just
throws hard
pitches inside has a lot of movement we
talk about the energy and the emotion
that he plays with
this is a really key component to what
the cubs do
back to the top for bets ookie's
frustrations have continued tonight with
a no for three
takes it outside ball four
that's the board for the first time
tonight
they're first and second with two gone
from muncie
monsieur
left field peterson coming on jock slows
down and that is out number three
time running third go ahead run it
second
in the air out towards right center
bellinger cody makes the ground here's
hayward mariznick advances and a set fly
and we're tied up at two and two as jack
peterson knocks in the time run so after
the lead off hit for baez he strikes out
rizzo he strikes out contreras the
pitcher's spot now and upcoming eric
sogar no balls one strike sogard with a
fly ball center field
bellinger's there he'll make the catch
and that's gonna do it aj pollock lux
has terrific speed at first the 1-1
pitch
hit in the air left field that goes
peterson half the wall it's gone
it's aj polish
his sixth of the season and the dodgers
take a four to two lead
the 2-0 muncie with a fly ball to deep
right field way back and it is gone
the dodgers offense has turned it on
four in the eighth it is now
one two pitch
and that's it 97 to finish the night
and the dodgers end the losing streak at
four with a 6-2 win over the cobs